Ohh.
Well, Austin.
There we go.
Hey, Kip.
How are you doing today?
There's been a, it's been a day. I literally just stepped out for my lunch and then, yeah, sorry for that. It took longer than it's supposed to. I literally just walked across the street, came back until I did.
That's fine, not a problem.
Ahh.
OK.
Um...
Where were we? What were we going to do? Oh, yeah, okay. So, yeah, so we could pick up from the email yesterday. If Vaughn has free time or time that he's not doing things, then he needs to reach out to us to tell us, hey, I have stuff to do or not to do. And then this is the second time I've had to do this, and I don't want there to be a third time.
just if you have time that is available, I can put you on something. We have stuff definitely to do.
Yeah.
So I had a one-on-one connect with one and he made sure that he will proactively reach out to you whenever he got less tickets to work on. And yeah, so won't happen again.
Okay.
OK.
Yeah, no, I appreciate it. It's helpful. And I know sometimes, like, it was just odd. It's because it's so out of character and then all of a sudden, yeah. But okay, I appreciate it. Thank you.
Yes.
What else? Anything else you would like to share?
Yeah, I'm waiting for you guys to give me an update on that, a defender checklist.
Yeah, he did send an email today, Juan.
With the this project scope.
Mm-hmm.
for your review. He just wanted you to review it and if there are any changes required.
Hello, Zobec.
Okay.
You can definitely let him know, let me know, and yeah.
I see that now. Yep, at 11:00. OK.
I am.
No.
Okay.
Okay, I'll take a look. And this is just a baseline of what the first thing should be. Oh yeah, this is a good first step. It looks like, you know.
No.
It looks like we're pulling it from AI, which is fine. I'm okay with that. And then, I know it says enable, but then the question would be, can he do that and how is he going to do that? So that's the next thing I'm going to want. Like, sure, if you're going to do this, then, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, okay. So I'll happily review this and I appreciate you getting this to me.
Yeah.
Mm.
Yes, the implementation plan, yes, so.
Yeah.
Perfect, perfect, perfect. I am working on, hopefully by...
Yeah, definitely.
Hopefully within two weeks I'll have official SLA items for you.
That's the goal. Yeah, they're porting. I have like...
OK.
five or six reports that are being edited and created or managed and then I can go through that way. I'm going to have for your knowledge in Halo, there is a time tracking capability. I'm sure you're aware of where you have to submit. So on Wednesday, so tomorrow at our 9:00 meeting.
Mhm.
I'm going to let everybody know, hey, starting next week, this is how their time, I'm going to track their time. So if I see their time, at the end of every day, they have to hit submit, right? So you're going to do your lunchtime through here as a break time. And then this is going to prepare us for in two weeks, this is how all time will be tracked for us internally here, period. We won't do, right now we're doing a weird handwritten thing.
and through Excel. So we're going to mix that and we're going to go directly through just everything through Halo, make it nice and simple, time's easily tracked. Hey, if you miss something and it happens, let me know what happened and let's add the time. And we'll go through that way.
Sure, definitely.
Perfect. Oh, another follow-up question, so sorry, was, do you have an internal time off or leave for Vaughn for about to have a baby?
Okay, so...
Yeah.
Not right now, because it completely depends upon the due date. So yeah, so once things are ready, he will let us know and then we will plan accordingly.
Okay.
No, so what I mean is like, is the due date is June 17th. So we are, everything goes great. She has the baby June 17th, whether it's plus or minus. Do you give him a day off or two days off? And so we can plan accordingly on our side, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, ideally we have, yeah, so we have paternal leave for three days.
Three days? Okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, so it will be 3 days.
Okay, let me put that in. We were unaware because this is our first time we've had working with someone with you who's had a baby. So...
Hoh.
Three days paternal, paternal leave.
Okay, I'll work with Eric and Tina and see where we are with that. I don't think that'll be a huge problem for us. Three days is sounds good. And 17, 18, 19. Yeah, okay.
Mm.
All right, what else? Anything else you want to share, Sarbjeet?
Karine.
No, no, no, everything else is good. I've not had a one-on-one with anybody in a couple months, so I do need to have a one-on-one with Vaughn. The goal is to...
The goal is next week. So I'll have my one-on-one again with Vaughn, you know, what he's looking for. And I should have an answer for you and for Vaughn next week for this defender thing that you sent me. And we can go on next steps and what expectations are.
Okay.
Yeah.
and how we can set this up to be a repeatable thing that we can just start rolling out to our clients.
Mhm.
Yes.
Definitely, definitely.
Sure thing. And regarding the presentation, you want me to email to you? You want to go through it right now?
Ryan.
You can email to me. I realize I was late, so you can email to me and I appreciate that. Yeah.
Okay, okay, sure, sure, sure thing. I will email it to you and yeah, you will be getting the CSAT survey for the month of June for one within this week, maybe in a day or two. So just keep an eye on your inbox and until, yeah. And yeah.
Okay.
I can do that.
That's all from my end.
OK, perfect. Perfect.
Thanks, thanks Kip. I apologize for running late. Yep, I appreciate it.
Okay. Yeah.
No, that's absolutely fine. No problem. So do reach out to me whenever you have anything to share, but the way you always do on the email, and I will definitely get back to you.
First of all, I appreciate it, Kip. Thank you. Have a good day. Thanks, you too. Bye bye.
Thank you, Austin. Bye bye.
Play.